we've talked about acting a lot tonight
but support obviously you know acting I
card you might know but you must you
must get so many young actors coming up
to you kind of like oh do you've any
advice so have you come up with like a
kernel of advice do you give them just
you can make them go away no I like to
give advice when people ask I and if
it's helpful for them I always there you
know what's what's the T thing you tell
them well it depends is different
depends on who it is who's asking me it
could be very personal or it could be
something that's a career move or this
or that but I'm pretty I think I'm
pretty good at that
okay boys do you think I could ever get
back in tryptic one of the few times I
would ever say maybe no didn't see you
in father Ted exactly
[Applause]
and the other thing is obviously you
know you wanted to be an actor that was
your ambition to be an actor you you
didn't set out to be a movie star but
that's that's happened so does a day go
by when people don't shout out you know
line some movies and things to you or
does that happen all the time
no I get that I don't get that very
often from people who are afraid to do
that to him
are do you remember that night we were
having dinner we were having dinner it
was Gay Pride Parade course we were
downtown and so he had his back to the
door and I was you know facing him and
all these queens came in all these drag
queens fabulous came in and when they
saw me it was like and they came around
the corner and they saw him it was like
[Music]
you